okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about fractions and mixed numbers so
working with fractions working with
mixed numbers this is something they
want you to know on the act usually
these questions occur earlier in the
test
but again you don't want to make a
simple mistake so let's just go through
the basic operations adding subtracting
multiplying and dividing fractions and
mixed numbers and then we're going to go
through
more of a typical type of example like
you would see on the act so first of all
a quick review here when you work with
mixed numbers an easy way to work with
mixed numbers is just to convert them
back into improper fractions so what you
can do is you take the denominator
times this whole number plus the
numerator
all over the denominator so what this
would be is 5 times 2 is 10
plus 3 is 13
so this is going to be
fifths same thing here 2 times 1 is 2
plus 1 is 3 all over 2 so plus
3 halves now what you can do is
you can
get a common denominator and you can see
the common denominator is ten that's the
smallest number that five and two both
go into it's is ten so what i'm going to
do is i'm gonna multiply this one by two
over two this one by five over five you
can see that's going to give us 26
tenths and this is going to give us 15
tenths and if we add those together we
get you keep the denominator but you add
the numerator so 26 plus 15 is 41 10.
now what we're going to do is we're
going to convert it back into a mixed
number 10 goes into 41 four whole times
with one left over so we put that one
over the 10. so it's going to be 4 and 1
10. so i think an easy way to do this is
just to you know convert these into
improper fractions first get common
denominators and proceed from there same
thing with subtraction let's just do
this one real quick 3 times 4 is 12 plus
1 is 13 all over 3
okay and then 6 times 2 is 12 plus 1 is
13 over 6. the common denominator here
is 6. let's multiply the numerator and
denominator here by two so that we have
a common denominator of six that's going
to be 2 times 13 which is 26 6
minus 13 6 which equals 13 6. 6 goes
into 13 how many times 2 with one left
over so this is 2 and 1 6. okay now with
multiplying and dividing
what we're going to do same thing let's
convert 2 times 5 is 10 plus 1 is 11
halves
5 times 1 is 5 plus 1 is 6 fifths and
then what you can do is you can multiply
the numerators and denominators and then
reduce or you can do something what's
called cross reducing which you can
reduce uh numerator and denominator on
the diagonals or just above numerator
and denominator like so so one wants you
want to be in the numerator one you want
to be in the denominator so like here
you can see two and six are both
divisible by two
okay two goes in here once two goes in
here three times now when i multiply
across it's been a little bit reduced
for us that's 33 over one times five
which is five
and then five goes into 33
6 whole times with 3 left over so that's
6 and 3 fifths
and then the last one here
we've got 4 9
okay divided by let's see 3 times 2 is 6
plus 2 is 8 3 but when you divide
fractions you can think of the keep it
change it flip it or you can think of
dividing as multiplying by the
reciprocal so you keep that first
fraction just as you see it there
four-ninths you change this to a
multiplication problem but you take the
reciprocal of the second fraction and
then what we can do is we can do that
cross reducing technique we talked about
up here
four and eight reduce to one over two
and then nine and three reduce one and
three
and when you multiply across you get one
and three times two is six so this just
comes out to 1 6. so these are kind of
the basic operations for fractions and
mixed numbers but let's look at a
typical example see if you can do this
one on your own pause the video and then
come back and check your work
so let's just say if you swam two and
two-sevenths of a mile
on monday right and one one third of a
mile on tuesday how far will you have to
swim on wednesday to have swam a total
of five miles
okay so go ahead and pause the video see
if you can do this one on your own and
we're going to go ahead and do it here
and double check your work so basically
let's see how far you've swam so far
you've swam two and two sevenths of a
mile plus one and one third okay
plus you're going to swim x miles on
wednesday to give you a total of five
miles right so let's just convert these
into improper fractions that's 14 plus 2
is 16 7
plus 3 times 1 is 3 plus 1 that's 4 3
plus x equals 5.
common denominator is 21.
okay so i'm going to multiply this one
by 3 over 3 that gives you 48 21st this
one multiply by 7 over 7 that gives you
28 21st
okay so if we add these together we get
let's see six that's 76.
21st plus x equals 5. now another
technique that you can use when you're
working with fractions is something
called clearing the denominators see all
these fractions you can think of
any whole number as a fraction by
putting it over 1 and then if we
multiply everything by the common
denominator which in this case is 21
that'll clear the denominators for us so
i'm going to multiply this whole thing
by 21 distribute that gives you 76
because here the 21s cancel out
plus 21x
equals 105.
okay so now let's just subtract the 76
from both sides so what does that give
you that's let's see 24
plus 5 is
29 and then divide by 21
and you can see that x equals one 21
goes into 29 one time with eight left
over so it'll be one and eight twenty
first
of a mile
okay so that's how you would go ahead
and solve this problem these problems
you know they're they're pretty easy you
can do these on your calculator um it's
easy to make little arithmetic mistakes
you might want to just you know do these
by hand but
just some simple operations it's good to
know how to work with fractions because
that's
something that you're going to test you
on on the act something typical like
this example we just did here